We do not know when it will be
safe to go outside.
We only know that day is not today.
We're in a silo. Ten thousand
people, one hundred forty-four floors.
There's a threat outside and we
don't know what the threat is.
And characters ask the dangerous
questions of why.
The show, at its core, is a mystery.
It deals with what is the truth,
who owns the truth, and who is
telling the truth.
Some mysteries are best left unsolved.
Juliette is constantly seeking
the truth.
The truth about the
bigger question of why we're there.
Don't you ever think about the
world beyond the silo?
There’s something going on and
that flame is picked up by Juliette.
She wants to know, “What’s being
kept from us?”
They want to erase the past and
anyone who tries to preserve it.
Juliette finding out the truth
creates a domino effect into a
huge chaos.
You need to stop doing what
you're doing.
Not until I find out what I want
to know.
They'll never let you.
The wool is being pulled over
the people of the Silo's eyes.
What is this place?
We think it's from before the rebellion.
Made me realize how
little we know about the Silo.
The thing that’s really
satisfying is just how deep it runs.
We do not know when it will be
safe to go outside. We only know
that day, is not this day.
Now!
And thereby, we remind you, that
here is safe-
[screams]
-and there is not.